the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
you
okay good afternoon today we're going to
go beyond the way we've spoken about
before we talked about how psychologists
measure the mind how neuroscientists
interrogate the brain and so now we'll
talk about the first human faculty that
we'll consider in a series of faculties
through the course vision how we see and
for today's lecture I got help from
millet or one of your teaching
assistants so one of the things we can
think about is what are the purposes of
vision what do we use sight for and
we'll talk about that problems of the
visual system has to overcome what are
the obstacles provision to work
accurately and efficiently and how does
the brain organization of vision
subserve the human capacity to see so
human perceptual abilities are amazing
as our perceptual abilities of many
species in different areas but humans
can detect a candle 30 miles away on a
dark clear night they can detect
cochlear displacement that's in your ear
equal to the width of a hydrogen atom
you can taste one teaspoon of sugar
even when it's mixed in two gallons of
water you can smell a drop of perfume
diffused into the space of a
three-bedroom apartment so the human
capacity to perceive the world in a
highly sensitive way is remarkable we're
gonna focus on vision specifically today
and think what do we use vision for
what's how does it serve us in dealing
with the world
and researchers have thought about two
major reasons that we see two purposes
of vision one of them is object
recognition recognizing things in the
world people we know words we can read
chairs tables animals all kinds of
things that we see out there we need to
know who they are what they are in order
to operate in the world and the second
one I was a little bit different
Navigation getting around in the world
when you're running when you're jumping
when you're reaching to grab something
you're not usually so interested much
interested in what something is as where
you're moving where you need to move to
avoid something being thrown at you so
two big purposes of vision what things
are and where they are so you can
navigate around quickly in the world and
when we think about purposes of vision
in this earth for what things are or
where the
psychologists and people working on
computer vision have recognized a series
of problems that are a visual problem a
system has to solve we have to link
unique images because when we see
something it almost always looked
different from one perceptual moment to
the next we can see the same person for
example but under different conditions
of illumination darkness or lightness or
shadows the angle we see them at the
distance we see them at the expression
on their face a smile or a frown shadows
that might be being cast occlusion a
thing blocking part of their face and
yet we can recognize a person very well
under all these circumstances so what
arrives in our eye is different from all
of these views but what we interpret
them is all the same that's a person I
know the same thing with letters we can
see letters and all kinds of fonts and
all kinds of handwriting and yet we can
interpret what they are in a uniform way
or body we can see bodies in all kinds
of different positions but our visual
system lets us know right away that it's
a person and so psychologists are try to
formalize these kinds of problems and
the ones of equivalence so something is
the same thing at different views
generalization something has a very
different shape or impoverished input
where there's the poor lighting or
something is complicated and you still
figure out what it is for getting around
in the world where things are in the
world you're moving through space and
trapping things and as many sources of
movement your eyes are constantly moving
your head is moving your body is moving
in the world and if it's just sort all
those out run quickly jumping world
spatially and so here's some example
here's a shape constancy problem that
where here's two different versions of a
cat it's trivial for you to know that
even though these things have different
shapes they represent the same thing but
that's an achievement of your visual
system to easily make that equivalence
across two very different shapes and we
know from computer vision how hard these
problems are no computer vision system
sees with anything like the generalized
ability of a very young child so our our
visual systems are so brilliant that
psychologists and vision scientists
really interrogate our visual system to
figure out how do we do it if people
didn't do this we think it'd be
impossible to accomplish
here's another example that's easily
solved by people not so easily solved by
machines if you see it something like a
car at different angles we know that's
the same thing pretty easily even though
again the information that arrives to
our eyes is radically different and the
same thing can be said of something like
all these different versions of the
letter C radically different shapes but
we can readily interpret almost all of
them this moment into two tough as a
letter C so our visual system does this
kind of brilliantly and also you can get
very impoverished views a key might be
covered by something close on a hook
there might be a book over here there
might be a fire hydrant over here or a
person and yet even though you've got
only partial information it's relatively
trivial to discover for you what it is
you're looking on or you can see things
like you've never seen before the pink
elephant of the this odd picture the
this striped theme them before but it's
not really a so again your visual system
is just so brilliant at matching what it
sees with what you know to figure out
what's in front of you so today we're
going to talk about how our minds and
brains allow us to see the world vision
and we'll talk about it in three parts
how philosophers and psychologists have
thought about the idea of seeing how
when information first enters your your
eye your retina which are the layers
cell of layers in the back of the eye
how that retinas already organized to
help you see the world and how that
information is then transported into the
cortex where higher level processing
lets you know where you are and what
you're looking at so the ideas about how
we learn to see the world have their
roots in philosophy for example john
locke is associated with the idea of the
blank rate or the blank slate tabula
Rosa he said let us suppose the mind to
be a white paper void of any characters
without any ideas
how comes it to be furnished whence it
comes the vast door which the busy and
boundless fantasy of man has painted
honor with an almost endless variety
where do we get the information for how
the world works when we look at it
and his answer that was experience that
we noticed things around us and
experience drives our understanding of
the world and that position that there's
a blank slate and we sort of learn
objectively from the world around us has
been called the Objectivist view and
maybe that we see the world because we
build up through experience knowledge
about to accurately represent what's
around us the alternative view has
emphasized the how much our mind
organizes what we see instead of what's
out there itself
it's the gestalt psychologists or
Gestalt views on perception say it's not
what's out there in the world but the
way our mind organizes and believes
what's out there
and these two things can come together
so for example when you think about how
you listen to a piano music comes from
piano and the same way a pianist strikes
chords there's things out there in the
world that you see the piano has certain
limitations it can sound like some
things but not others it can't be a
clarinet there's constraints in the
world and what's possible to see or
what's out there but that our part and
our perceptor a VOC by nature in this
way but they are personal and not a copy
of nature in other words we each
individually figure out what's going on
there by our own experiences and
interpretation and they're exactly that
interpretation not a simple mirroring or
copy of nature so I'm going to try to
convince you of something that might not
be obvious to people when they first
think about it that vision is an
interpretation of the world around us
it's not simply a video camera or a
mirror it's an active calculation of
what's out there and we see through
inference when we believe that what we
see and that visual illusions and you've
seen some before I'll show you some
again are not just illusions to trick
people and confuse them but they're
demonstrations of the gap between what's
actually out there in the world and how
we interpret it most of the time we're
don't have illusions we don't walk into
walls we don't miss identify people we
know commonly because illusions are rare
because our minds and brains have
involved to interpret the world that's
out there and the system works so
brilliantly coupled with the environment
that we actually live in that we don't
think about it so the person in the
street says well what do I need to see I
open my eyes but that's because our
visual system works so brilliant
effortlessly and automatically as such a
calculating machine that dat's why it
feels so simple so here's a one small
example and I'll show you a number of
visual illusions that show us how we're
constantly interpreting even the most
simple thing so for example here is two
people and we're not worried that this
is one of the shortest men you've ever
seen because we know through perspective
this person standing back there even
though if they were standing right next
to somebody you'd worry about the size
of that person but so we're constantly
interpreting information by the context
in which we see it here's another
example of the choice of interpretation
so you can see Avaaz or you can see two
faces here usually it's hard for people
to see them both simultaneously that
tend to flip back and forth but you can
choose the interpretation of what you
see so let me take one example where
people have studied a lot which is the
issue of brightness constancy so here's
the here's the problem for the visual
system the ambient brightness the
brightness around us varies and
staggering ratios when we're outdoors in
the Sun and sometimes even that's not
constant right sometimes it's a bright
day sometimes is a cloudy day sometimes
we're indoors under bright conditions or
less bright conditions so huge changes
in the ambient illumination or in
shadows will make it even more
complicated that means in a purely
measurement sense in a purely physics
sense a piece of coal and sunlight
reflects ten times as much light as snow
in the shade so think about that for a
moment you're not disturbed if you see a
piece of coal inside or outside they
both look to you like black dark pieces
of coal and snow looks pretty much the
same to you if it's inside or outside
but if your visual system work like a
simple objective light meter you would
conclude that the piece of coal and the
sunlight is a much brighter thing and an
objective sense than snow in the shade
and yet you never make that conclusion
because you're constantly automatically
without effort adjusting mentally for
the ambient like
addition so we use brightness all the
time to help us figure out is that a
piece of coal or sunlight but that
brightness perception is constantly
adjusted to interpret brightness in the
context we're sitting in and perceptual
psychologists have worked on how people
calculate this so here's the example of
a dark letter T again the black T would
be ten times brighter outdoors than
white paper is indoors okay so so you
would
and yet you're never bothered by that
you can read a newspaper or something
else indoors or outdoors with equal ease
because people are calculating the ratio
of the ambient lighting lower inside
much brighter outside from the Sun and
using that information to make
inferences about the relative brightness
of a stimulus they're looking at and
there's all kinds of examples or
illusions that show us this so for
example here you detect a white tile in
the shade and a gray tile in brightness
and that's how you interpret it but
that's because you're taking already
into account without even thinking about
it for a moment the fact that this is in
the shadow and this is in the bright
light you're right in your
interpretation but if we lose something
if we show a constant background you can
see that those two are actually
identical in brightness the same thing
you could take a look at this cube and
this cube is part of these Rubik's cubes
this looks orange this looks brown
you're adjusting for light as you make
those interpretations and if you make
the background constant you can see
there's a identical in color and
luminance so this shows you that we're
constantly making these interpretations
only these tricks of visual illusion
make us realize that our inferences are
occasionally wrong but they're
incredibly right almost all the time so
here's another example of taking a local
luminance into account so you're
deciding this is typically people see
this as a lighter gray and this is a
darker gray again they're using the
contrast that surrounds it to make that
interpretation because if we give it a
constant background you can see that in
an objective sense the two are identical
people use edges as a very powerful
source of information to make these
inferences and you can see that in one
moment because this boundary here is
used to make judgments about the
relative brightness around an object so
you just do this that boundary
disappears and the two things look
equally gray one above the other or in a
less spectacular but measured example
here's two different shades of gray and
if you're in a light meter objectively
looking at how much light is reflected
from this here that changes this looks
almost the same as this but really
there's just a manipulation at the
boundaries again here's a light meter
here's the boundary so these two sides
are really identical it's just been
manipulated by the boundary and you can
see that because if you get rid of that
boundary now you can see that these two
sides are equally bright another example
again of how we're constantly using
local information about brightness to
make judgments about objects is here you
see a picture of a woman here's her
forehead here's her darker hair but in
fact that's a judgment and
interpretation because if we cover up
the surrounding information the hair is
identical to the face here's some other
illusions not all about brightness but
again they're just reminders that work
what we see is constantly a calculation
and interpretation of many factors so
here's a fun spiral you can see a
zooming around going from inner
tightness and one unwinding peripherally
and so we can add a dot to that and now
we can let this travel around to the
middle top you can see it's not quite
making the middle and we can try that
again because in fact in this picture
every line every circle is a circle and
none of them are connected one to the
other they just appear that way this is
a illusion that Richard Gregory
describes he was inspired because he saw
a wall in a cafe that looked like it had
not been well assembled by the person
building it as if they had been you know
consuming something from the cafe as
they built the wall and
you know bizarrely having all kinds of
lines that are not lined up as you
expect in the well-constructed tiles in
a wall but in fact every line here is
perfectly straight and you're
interpreting the black and white edges
to confuse you about the lining up
across the horizontal this is very
striking here's a Rubik's cubes that
again now that they're adding one more
story into this which is colored but
just as we use that often in everyday
sight of course to make conclusions
about things and here you can see the
difference between for example this
yellow cube and this brown cube
what did I want to do okay yeah you
can't you can see the difference between
this brown cube sorry let me get my
illusion correct and this darker cube
lighter brown and Jericho Brown but if
we cover those up those are identical
and they're gray here's another one that
shows you it's not just the color itself
but the spatial location so here's a
pink circle near the middle of this
display and here's a sort of more orange
one so we're just simply going to expand
those out and get a bigger and bigger
and as it's moving across your eye
even though objectively it's remains
pink and orange or the things that led
you to interpret that is it gets big
enough the color difference disappears
to your perception and sometimes you can
get and this is a very complicated one
illusions I don't know if it's working
for you but that these things are
actually turning even though none of
them are moving at all
okay and one last simple example you
know here's yellow on gray here sort of
a light gray on yellow but in fact these
X's are identical and you can see that
when they meet here so again we're
constantly interpreting color shape
brightness by things that are
surrounding it and serve everything as
being the product of an interpretation
not what's out there in an objective
sense itself and so if we think about
this objective this view that that can't
be right that the luma this objective
this view would be that everybody sees
everything differently all the time
that'd be a confusing world of
hallucinations we don't live there
either mostly so we think it's because
there's a relationship between this to
us or our synthesis we perceive only
within limits of our nervous system
there's a way that we see the world but
the way that our nervous system computes
and it makes inferences about the world
reflects many properties of the world
that are efficient and accurate so how
do we get information into our brains to
see so if you were to design a system
that was hopelessly failed the first
thing you would do is think the visual
system is going to fail I mean what did
the first thing it does is it takes
objects in the world and it flips them
upside down and how they're perceived in
the eye the front of the eye the back of
the eye here's the retina and the first
place in your brain that sees something
is in the back of your eye you think you
can put it in the front of your eye and
the information bounces back into the
deepest part of the island comes out and
leaves through the optic nerve you also
know from prior classes that the world
is organized by left and right visual
fields instead of the way we intuitively
think about the world
let's take a look closer look at the
retina these layers of cells in your eye
that begin vision so light comes in and
bounces through the back and here are
the rods and cones where vision begins
the cones are primarily near the fovea
the rods are primarily peripheral and
I'm reminding you again that as innocent
as the optic nerve leaves it goes
the optic chiasm the fibers get sorted
out by whether they're having
information from the left or right side
of the world and then enter the cortex
that way within the retina within your
eye
here are the sort of a graphic of the
different kinds of cells here's an
actual what the cells actually look like
and here's a blow-up of these remarkable
of cones these larger entities and the
neuron and the cone and the rods that
you can see are very small but many of
them and a big thing difference between
rods and cones that the rods are
receptive to information that only one
wavelength they're effectively
colorblind we'll come back to that but
that's a good wavelength to pick up
information for example in low light the
cones are selective for blue or red or
green that's the stuff of seeing color
but it doesn't operate too well unless
you have a pretty well illuminated
situation and the rods and cones have a
striking physical organization so here's
the distribution of cones for color
pretty much all of them in the fovea in
the middle part of the retina and then
the rods are spread out peripherally so
there's this big difference in where
they're located and another big
difference is that the cones the ones
that respond to color and that are in
the middle of the fovea are have an
almost one-to-one relationship between
the receptors for color information and
the neurons that leave the eye with
information that will go into the brain
the Rives have a many to one
relationship many rods are contributing
for a combined calculation of some kind
to a single neuron that leaves the brain
so you can already see at the very first
moment of reception from the rods and
from the cones there are different kinds
of processes are being begun as you
begin to see
two ideas have been very helpful for
understanding how visions are organized
in the brain a receptive fields the
retinopathy receptive fields are simply
an area of external space is a physical
spot in space in which a stimulus
activates a neuron so neurons early in
vision will respond to specific
locations in space when you're looking
straight forward one neuron might cover
this area another neuron might cover
that area and so forth retinotopic
refers to topographic or special
integrins maps of visual space across
the restricted region of the brain and
so retinopathy keeps these receptive
fields lined up so if there's neuron is
seeing this spot this guy retinotopic
map it's the next spot stays next to it
and the next spot stays next to it so
you can reconstruct what you see based
on a lot of very local glances at the
environment and then it travels into
from the eye through the optic nerve
into something called a lateral
geniculate nucleus that nucleus is
simply a collection of cells this is
part of the thalamus and from there the
fibers will travel into the cortex to
begin conscious visual perception and
you have one on the left and one on the
right of the lateral geniculate nuclei
and if you look at this blown up on this
is a sample from a monkey but the human
one looks very similar you can see one
two three four five six layers of cells
in each lateral geniculate nucleus the
first to look a little bit different if
you look carefully they're comprised of
larger cells the other four are
comprised of smaller cells so people
describe the cell layer is made up of
larger cells as magnocellular big cells
and the other four layers is
parvocellular or small cells that
magnocellular to cell in layers tend to
have large cells a lot of their
information come from the rods the black
and white elements good for seeing in
low vision they have large receptive
fields that cover relatively large
patches of the world for each neuron
three times larger than the
parvocellular ones the neurons fire
rapidly transiently are color blind
they're good and low contrast low
lighting the parvocellular ones are
smaller they get a lot of their input
from the
they have smaller receptive fields they
have slow sustained responses they don't
turn on and off very quickly their
wavelength sensitive so they can respond
to color they operate best when things
are very bright they're unique to
primates and they're ten times more of
them but again even before you get to
the cortex there's this huge
organization between two modes or
pathways of perception to construct the
world as you see it and then we've gone
over before that as you leave and nuclei
the lateral geniculate nuclei then the
next fiber pathway takes you into the
primary visual cortex in the back of
your brain now vision is so important
for primates and people that when people
estimate how much of the neocortex is
devoted to different modalities a common
estimate is that about half of the brain
is primarily devoted to vision let 11%
to touch 3% of all audition these are
ballpark estimates but it shows you that
how visual we are with our fellow
primates
there's many specialized areas within
the human visual cortex
estimated some years ago is 32 distinct
areas each performing a different tasks
lots of specialization and another
fascinating sort of aspect of vision is
proliferation as we go up into higher
stations of visual processing so in one
lateral genetic that nucleus in your
brain and you have two of them one on
the left and one on the right you have
about a million neurons they will send
information that will be interpreted by
about 250 million neurons in your visual
cortex those will communicate to about
400 million neurons the next level of
processing and finally there'll be
something like 1.3 billion visual
cortical neurons in the brain overall in
a gross estimate so it's as if to
discover what you're seeing you're
having larger and larger populations of
neurons unpacking the mystery but
whether initially came into the brain
very impoverished information that's
expanded to begin to under
and what you need to perceive a face or
a word or physical movement so a single
lateral geniculate not good be estimated
we'll take 600 cortical neurons to
interpret what this lateral genican has
been exposed to here is this area in the
visual cortex with information arrives
first into your brain and primary visual
cortex and when we think about cortex in
perception and in several modalities
when the striking thinks is how it's
organized to achieve certain goals
so here's we're gonna switch for a
moment to the parts of your brain that
move your body motor cortex or that have
your sense of touch and when people
stimulate these and look about what
they're related to for example in
patients undergoing treatment for
epilepsy or an animal studies support
this where you can do much more
extensive experimentation a very
striking thing occurs which is the
number of neurons devoted to different
parts of your body are radically
different than your actual body size so
this funny-looking what so called
homunculus represents how many neurons
for example in your motor cortex are
devoted to different parts of your body
so it turns out you know that we do
incredible things with our hands so we
devote it seems like a tremendous amount
of this area to the hand that's why that
looks so large we don't tend to do
there's a reason we do handshaking and
handwriting and typing with our hands
and not with our hips because although
our hips are physically larger than our
hand we devote incredibly small number
of neurons to do that so it's a trick of
the brain given a certain limited size
to blow up it's representation of what
needs to be done brilliantly and to
reduce its representation of parts of
the body that it doesn't have to do too
much with so what's blown up your hand
things to do with your face so that you
can speak your tongue because it has to
accomplish a lot in terms of speech in
terms of eating and things like your
toes and ankle are gypped of
representation because you don't do that
much that's brilliant so it's a very
clever strategy by the brain to devote
the amount of neural resources to make
that
part of your body accomplished either
very complicated things are very simple
things and if people on the outside
looked like this this is what they would
look like her giant hands giant head and
very shriveled up trunk so so that's not
what we look like but that's the way our
brain represents us are our bodies so
that we can have fantastically
complicated control of our hands and
things having to do with speech around
our mouth it's different for different
modalities for hearing things are
organized by frequency tonotopy
for vision things are organized in two
ways the spatial relations are
maintained they have to be so you know
as different neurons saw different
receptive fields how is that all kept up
here's a kind of a rough experiment
where a monkey saw before it was as they
politely say sacrificed a display like
this this is the brain of the monkey
flattened out and you can see has this
representation like this now you could
say well that's how we see we line
everything up but this is not the part
of our brain that we associate with
conscious perception at all but if you
didn't keep the spatial information
information aligned correctly you could
never interpret things in the end
correctly that go together like
different parts of a hand or different
letters within a word in humans it's
also in the back of the brain it also
keeps spatial information but what do
humans do and other primates they
greatly expand the central part of
vision so here's a central part of
vision the so called fovea which is a
small part of the visual display here's
the everything else that's in peripheral
vision so this dark green dark purple
but when it comes to the representation
in the visual cortex this small area of
what we see becomes pretty large its way
over-represented so just as the motor
cortex over represents the hand the
visual cortex over represents the cone
fovea part of the brain so they can do
much more examination much more
computation on that small fovea area so
that's why it matters tremendously where
people put their eyes where they put
their eyes
we're neural machinery is dedicated to
do its most brilliant analysis and
peripheral regions which are large and
vision get relatively small
representation all we do in the
periphery is kind of notice if something
is whizzing at our head and for that we
don't need to be that sophisticated now
what do neurons communicate in primary
visual cortex well this is a sort of
seminal Nobel prize-winning work from
Hubel and Wiesel at Harvard who
discovered that what neurons respond to
and primary visual cortex are is the
orientation of a piece of something like
this so here's a neuron that loves a
little bit of a stimulus notice that
this orientation here's each of these
lines of the neuron as a de neuron
firing it generalizes if a lock if a bar
is closed an orientation you will still
like it somewhat and if the bar moves
away from its preferred orientation it
won't respond at all
so these neurons are coding something
about local orientation of little lines
those little lines will be assembled
later on in the brain to represent a
letter a word a book a face a chair and
so on but this part these neurons simply
know they're seeing a line of this angle
or that angle that will be assembled
later on for an entire conscious percept
and then that information will go from
primary visual cortex into pathways that
have two quite different properties but
turn out to be the sort of super
information processing pathways of your
brain and my brain so where do we first
learn about this fundamental
organization of how we see into two
giant highways of information processing
well the first studies where lesion
studies and monkeys and I'll show you
work in humans as well and that major
discovery was this that in our brains
there's a so called a where pathway that
goes up in the brain into the parietal
cortex and a what pathway that goes into
temporal lobe or lower cortex and if you
make lesions on these in these different
regions one form of vision is spared and
one is impaired in selective ways so how
did it discover this so again here's the
big picture we're early visual
processing information
a white pathway to know what objects are
a face a word a chain
or where things are that you might run
to grab or jump over so here was the
experiment it was pretty simple here
were two food wells and monkeys that
were eager to get food will get rewarded
if they would pick the correct food well
they wouldn't they didn't see where the
the food was that was hidden but they
would get to pick one or the other and
in one task they would have to tick
which food well is closer to this
stimulus that's a where tasks where is
this located that's the piece of
information that will tell me where to
get my food and you can see here's the
performance of the animal who's there
errors so it's good to be low they're
eager to get their food but look at the
if the animal had a surgical lesion in
the parietal cortex the where pathway
they were very poor performing this task
as if they couldn't appreciate the
spatial relation between where the
cylinder was located and the food well
the other had monkeys who were had
lesions made in the temporal cortex were
poor when they had to make this task
they would see two different objects and
they were taught that one always meant
that's where the food is let's pretend
as the cylinder so that in order to know
the correct answer they would say okay
is it next to this object or this object
that's a what discrimination is it a
cylinder or a cube and now the temporal
lobe lesions were the ones that affect a
performance so is if one part of your
brain tells you where things are
envisioned parietal lobe and one tells
you what they are the temporal lobe
so that's lesion studies in monkeys but
there's very interesting things about
when we look at the what cells
communicate in these two pathways that
makes sense in what we understand to be
the goals of these systems so for
example in the where pathway and the
parietal cortex many neurons pick up
information from the fovea the central
part of vision but the majority are
sensitive to stimuli in the periphery so
if you imagine a good thing to know if
you're running because in the periphery
are the things coming at your head you
know things to avoid you might grab
something here if you need to grab it
there you would want to have a lot of
peripheral information for spatial
things around you and in fact if a
monkey was looking at this spot which is
away entirely from
stimulus it would respond to both a
large and a small stimulus in the
periphery quite strongly
so these neurons are responding to a
pretty broad range of space where things
could happen neurons in the what pathway
have almost their entire responsiveness
in the fovea because you know what
something is if you're reading a word
and looking at it if you're looking at a
face that then figuring out who the
person is so it's not it's only
responding these kinds of neurons to
information in the center but it has
some very interesting properties even at
the level of singer neurons so here's a
survey depiction of an experiment now
from a monkey you're looking at a single
neuron or a small group of neurons and
you present something like a hand and
you can see that those neurons really
like the hand now don't forget for a
primary visual cortex it just sees lines
it doesn't think of a entire object but
by the time you get to the higher levels
of vision its encoding an entire object
and then you can do experiments that
basically interrogate what does this
neuron discover in the world what is it
interested in so you take the turn the
hand over it's still very understood you
show it a less detailed hand it's still
a very interested maybe a bit less but
it's still very interested a hand this
way where all the spatial relations have
changed still recognized as a hand still
liquid recognized as a handle with a bit
less enthusiasm but now a mitten which
kind of looks like a hand right that
barely counts as a hand at all that
neuron has lost interest in coding that
as a hand and then you've showed other
things that have some similarity in
shape like for these all at four
elements in them like four fingers this
neurons not responding at all it's not
that it has four things or lines it's a
hand and and you could even worry about
things well maybe just because it's from
a person but if they see the face at
these this neuron doesn't care okay so
it's nothing about the gross shape or
that it's a person this neuron is
specialized for weally for spotting a
hand and not only that these kinds of
neurons already have the properties we
described that our big problems for
vision so here's a neuron that's
responding to an upright face but it's
still having a respond
if the face is turned on its side pretty
well face is turned upside down a little
less well but it's still responding to a
face if the face is distant it's still
responding
if the face changes expression is still
responding and if it put a green filter
on it so you have a Martian person it's
still responding so all kinds of ways
that face changes in the world this
neuron is still firing and interestingly
this neuron was firing for one of the
experimenters but it wasn't too
interested in the other experimenter so
it's a neuron that's generalizing all
the different views that you might have
of a person but it's responding to one
neuron versus another and there's been a
lot of fun in monkey neurophysiology
stuff there's a so called jennifer
aniston self where's monkey where
researchers have discovered neurons and
monkeys that seem to respond to Jennifer
Aniston for whatever reason and other
specific you know famous people although
not particularly meaningful to the
primates and of course in human brain
imaging you can do tasks that emphasize
what an object is or where it is and
corresponding to the monkey work we see
activation in this where pathway towards
the parietal cortex if you have to make
a spatial judgment where things are
located or in the sort of lower temporal
lobe what pathway you have to make a not
a judgement about what object you're
looking at so that lines up and intact
humans very much with what we see in
primates with invasive studies so we're
going to end today by discussing two
kinds of lesions in humans and some
spectacular impairments in the what or
where pathway so let me get you ready
for these films for a moment so one film
you're gonna see it's a patient who has
a great injury to the parts of the brain
the parietal cortex that's observe our
ware system so this is so-called
daylon's syndrome in the neurology these
are bilateral injuries that means on
both sides of the brain and the parietal
region they're pretty good at knowing
what something is because the temporal
lobe pathway the what pathway is intact
but they have problems in knowing where
things are reaching for things where to
put their gaze estimating distances and
navigation
in general so I'll show you an example
of a patient like this and then the
converse a patient who has big problems
in the wet system and we'll start with
that and I'll tell you just one last bit
of information to think about that the
what and where distinctions sometimes is
not as complete in every way as you
might imagine but and so sometimes
people have said really the we're system
is better described is not where things
are but the information you need for
physical action in the world which is
very close to where but it's a little
bit different and let me give you the
kind of what type of information but the
where system still seems to have in it
so here's a patient with extensive
damage in the what system in the lower
parts of the brain and posterior for
vision
terrible perception of shapes and
orientation of shapes very bad what
ability but and she was asked and to
reach with with like an envelope to a
slot at different orientations and
what's striking is even though her hand
was a distance away so she would have to
think you know what is the angle I would
need to approach it with she was
terrible when she actually moved her
hand towards the slot she was
surprisingly good so let me show you
just the feeling so if this patient
would have to put her hands so that this
letter would fit into this slot you know
she was very good port spatial relations
and so sorry knowing what things were
and so she couldn't line them up at all
but now they said but please put your
hand out and just stick it in and as her
hand approaches it she changes her
orientation in this correct because she
needs in order to do things like to grab
something to think about when you grab
something like a pencil or a cup you
need a little bit of knowledge to know
what it is you wouldn't grab things
similarly whether they could spill
easily or be pointy or painful a little
bit of what information it helps you
guide even something like a simple
reaching which is a spatial task so it's
not so much maybe that the where system
is
only we're but it has just enough
information to guide actions in the
world which has a tiny bit of
information about what things are that
you're jumping over if you're gonna run
into something is it likely to be soft
or hard
you